uh i brought some food for the office
mac and cheeseburgers that's very nice
i didn't know if you could eat that so i
brought you this just in case that's
amazing
that's [ __ ] amazing over here
you heard your uh training card guys so
yeah something
this is a beast this is a beast i love
oh it's so peachy too
that is what is up i guess i could just
jump into yeah i don't know if you know
anything really about me or what i got
going on give it up give me it all
um i created the aims worth my message
so sports bars around new york city
grown nationally right now um and we're
kind of through a weird transition in
our company because we grew so
fast and i feel like the culture in the
communities
has kind of dissipated in the sense
becomes more vanilla
because yeah it's further from the sun
it's just like boom boom boom boom boom
and now
you know that's what happens to
everything yeah everything just so you
know
yeah everything now some things go
get it back and they become nike yeah
and other things lose it
and those are all the things we knew
once we're hot and they're not right
yeah for sure
um but i'll just tell you my story
really so always been a super hard
worker um
worked in delhi's my whole life as a kid
i remember like my uncle picked me up
4am for my christmas eve
to get the mozzarella and roll it with
the lobster
that guy always a hard worker um one
national championship in soccer and u16
soccer team got a scholarship to go play
university rhode island
quit my senior year over a girl um you
know a lot of people say don't live with
regret
but i live within my regret to never
make a stupid child's decision like that
again
um because i could have played
professional soccer which is crazy
actually two years ago
the red bulls asked me to try out at 31.
i mean
and i'm in like little underwear taking
the dude next to me he's like how old
are you wrong 31
i'm like how old are you 15. his parents
dropped it off
so it's just crazy that i had that
opportunity um that's cool
so i moved to new york city with 400 in
my pocket my dad was a school teacher my
mom's
a hairdresser and i just said [ __ ] it
i'm gonna move to new york city i have
no job and figure it out so i guess
bartended and i always had a network
from going to the university of rhode
island because everyone came back
so i did my thing there my sister at the
time was a prominent hair
colorist for warren comey her client was
rachel you could tell
at the time rachel was like listen i
need a kid who wants to work to be my
assistant at the nightclub in the
hamptons june
in the hamptons i know ryan harwood and
the locust they used to be my clients
they used to come and spend a lot of
money so you can tell ryan
is he around here he might be around
here yeah so see if howard's right
we had dune out there in the hamptons
and i met my partner machindell there so
i was
rachel utah's assistant picking up her
laundry i get it walking her dogs doing
my thing
i was enamored by the business you know
we had leonardo capricorn and athletes
people
loved it money everywhere i had a rent
control department my rent was for uh
six hundred dollars a month i lived in a
little railroad
studio so i said if i can make two g's
cash a week
i got something isn't the hands i'll do
it so i did that
and everyone started noticing my people
skills and i was able to network and do
my thing and treat everything like it's
my living room and make it nice for
people at the nightclub
so then that just opened so many doors
for me so my partner now
hired me um and i learned everything
from bus boy
to being in the kitchen to being a
manager doing everything there
so in 2009 we're sitting on market was
crashing you know it was during that
tough time so we didn't really know what
we wanted to do but we had a space on 26
between 6th and 7th
which is which is the og ainsworth so we
said let's create an aims with an angel
to 2 6 and poker
terrible hand in poker we're on 26th
street and we said that's great and it
never works out we can say it ain't
[ __ ] so we created ainsworth and now
um we're about to have nine angels doing
nashville this uh month coming
how many are in new york we have four in
new york and where are they jersey
26 between six and seven thirty third
park in madison
uh east village and we just opened
financial district
so we have that going on so where are
they in jersey
two we have one in um newark and hoboken
right next financial center so
throughout this whole process you know i
was able to and i've
always been a big fitness guy in sports
so i'm kind of in a tough position right
now because i have this great business
we're about to be
a 40 million company in sales this year
and i also have this
fitness aspiration to me and you know
motivating and getting people inspired
we're just on the cover of men's health
last year for south america um
in latin and mexico so i have these
opportunities right now it's like how do
i blend these
two restaurant fitness i'm a new dad and
nine month old son
best friend the world thank you my wife
was a journalist at cnn
so it's like how do we make everything
one
and how can i continue to grow my
personal brand that will
entail grow the ainsworth brand at the
same time so we can keep moving forward
like we're going to nashville on monday
so evan and i will go into nashville
evan's my head of sales uh we'll go into
nashville and we'll infiltrate the whole
fitness market and the scene and get
people in for tours
and we'll become a local part of their
local community and i do that really
well through fitness because that's what
i can do
very well because people gravitate
towards that through my instagram and
everything so how many people follow you
instagram i'm about to have 60
000. and it's all organic and that's
just me you know like
doing my thing and don't hedge it it's a
real number yeah so
i just don't know and i would love to
get some advice from you on
how i can continue to grow that personal
brand
in that sense or just continue doing
what i'm doing i mean it's like i'm
patient you know
for the first 10 years of my career i
didn't enjoy a summer i missed weddings
i miss birthday parties i mean so it's
like
it's very similar to my story exactly
the work for me i get it i [ __ ] don't
care i love it
yeah i mean listen the whole like the
whole like deli thing and
and you punt in your 20s like you're
preaching
right like preach i lived in new jersey
i was in new york city
nine nights in my twenties nine
nine at least you had fun straight up at
least you had fun punching you know
punting your your your twenties in the
setting you were in is ver i mean i
really i you know i really pumped in my
20s
straight up so i have empathy and i
understand uh
i think it's more of the same you know
truth is
there is no hack there's a couple things
i'll give you one very smart piece of
advice
don't create friction for your audience
here's what i mean by that you can't
just be on instagram
because if the person that thinks you're
really cute or cool or smart
in nashville like if she's a 37 year old
fitness influencer
who is also a real estate agent and
she's in her car all the time
you need to feed her your podcast so
today we launched our podcast so
my buddy rob was just here in the other
day of the cross player yeah yeah so
he's a very dear friend of mine
starting our podcast i love it it's
called the four because my principles
are
the fs4s family fitness fashion
food that's cool so we're launching that
today
look i think i honestly think it's about
my point of view i always say do what i
do not like listen to what i say
i poured all my money into it into
people
to be able to be a full-pledged cnn
media company
like i'm [ __ ] more of a media company
right now in the actual sense of a media
company
on april 2018 than most of the biggest
media companies
like i have more resources and pumping
out more content properly
in an instagram youtube medium linkedin
facebook snapchat alexa world
than like the biggest media companies in
the world yeah because i
guess the world's future no you
shouldn't alexa no thank you
uh alexa stop so i think that um
you know i think that that's the game
you know having empathy nine month old
you know not having a sense of like what
you've done with like let's say
apartment or home or what you and your
wife
need for like luxuries but it's
literally a basic p l just like running
a business
you know it i would look at on the
personal brand side
your intake of dollars and then and
again
if your partner and my partners believe
this if your partner believes
that it's the best interest of the
ainsworth if the overhead of
an audio guy written gal uh the mean gal
the video guy if that goes into the
aimsworth p l fine like that's
you know you understand what i'm saying
that's you and your partner decide and i
have a mix
there's certain things that come out of
my pocket and there's things that vayner
which i do also
got it so on your side yeah anything
personally for me
doesn't touch understood on your side i
would pour as much money into people
to build the infrastructure to produce
content constantly
at scale contextual for platform in
written form audio
video and pictures yeah so many people
are reaching out to me like you're
helping me thank you for helping
me louisiana reached out to me i need to
lose 30 pounds
and i we we accomplished that goal
together i don't know i got it all
through dm
so it's like how can i really take it to
the next level well what's
you know everybody has to define next
level are you saying monetize that
opportunity
like i don't even know i i just you
understand by the way i don't think
that's a bad thing
for sure i need to know what next level
is for me next level
but need to hear it out for me next
level is complete penetration of
awareness
that's what i want well then you should
charge for nothing
so i just did a fitness retreat in miami
at the one hotel
uh a month ago yep 200 people came so i
totally get it and
it's not really a money thing for me
because i have nice income from our
business our business and you know we'll
be there at the end of this exactly so
it's for me it's just how can i get in
front of so many more people and be more
impactful
hire more people to continue to just
keep pushing and growing and growing
on your personal level though
this yeah that's it
the [ __ ] are they doing the [ __ ] are
those 20 people doing
they're you know yeah they're they're
biz deving they're developing
that nerd in the corners building my
facebook message bot
so like like you know he's filming like
andy's
strategizing everything seth's working
on the audio you know
um soph right now is dming influencers
that have
the the enough awareness and engagement
that it feels like there could be
something worth my time
you know senan is focusing on pre-roll
youtube video
tyler's my admin you know actually like
you know we're starting to get some
awareness with um athletes that are
coming in celebrities so
um saquon barkley just trained with me
at
equinox and he ate at the restaurant
robert the player on the cardinals that
you can do
he was supposed to come uh i guess just
you know that's i know him
anything could happen yes but uh so
that's also another angle that we've
been playing casper smart
guess they're smart to shrink
so i'm getting involved now with a lot
of different i guess door
doors are opening i think it's not only
is it speaking engagements is it telling
me listen
listen bro you know you know i know all
this stuff meaning
you know the answers the like all you
have to do is more
the answer to your question is more so
like
i'll give you one show let me show you
brother thursday do it do it
let me give you let me give you a uh a
really good uh comp
when you have the right workout and
eating regimen
the answer is more and for a longer
period of time
and you'll see results right for sure i
mean i preach it all day it's how i
think about this
like you should have a post on linkedin
every day for business professionals
for health and fitness you're going to
get more of the wall street crowd coming
to the ainsworth you're going to have
people that have hedge fund money that
are going to want to give you 50 million
literally your linkedin strategy is more
important than everything
because you're going to get the guy or
the gal who wants to write you a 50
million dollar check to build a 250
million dollar fitness
empire and then you'll decide if that's
the right move or not right okay cool
but that's not the natural place where
people go right yeah i would never agree
to do that see well that's like my
dick's thing like i got you know
nobody's coming here by the way none of
you guys are coming here for because i'm
cute
but this is you know this is what you
know like this is what we're here for
i i think i you know what i mean i think
your linkedin strategy could be ballers
[ __ ]
like if it's all under the guise of like
you know fitness for professionals
content on linkedin is balling but
here's how i would do it i don't know
how you are as a writer
but i'm not it's funny being a five-time
new york times bestseller who can't put
two sentences together i mean my wife is
like a beast yeah that's me
right i wasn't even thinking about it
what i would do is film all day
and then let transcriptions come from it
awesome sure more the same
yeah thank you more the same i would
take as much you know to me
it's very basic everything that's a
luxury in your life on the p
l of your home life you and your wife
look at each other and be like
do we you know if you take one vacation
here could it be zero if you take four
could be one
like it's literally that no let me tell
you every time
i cashed in on things i regretted it the
apartment i bought on the pretty side
cost me more facebook and twitter stock
[Music]
straight up every time i've made a play
it cost me because i'm on the offense
and so taking money out for stuff
means it's not money to use got it
right now i think the biggest thing that
can crush for you is if you can really
go there
and afford maybe you can maybe you can't
but if you can afford
a four-person staff and like you know
like people are trying to get like
half pregnant on one person like yo you
know how it is like
all the influencers in the space right
now they're like one like they'll have
management and teams but like
an over you know it's really cool to be
like yo you take ten twenty thirty
percent off of whatever you bring in you
killing eat
that's easy you writing a [ __ ] check
for 55 000
for an employee that's different right
um
that's what i did just you know have the
empathy to know what the score is right
now
over communicate i love that you come in
and say yo i want
i just met with gary vee i believe him
like here's the jam i think it will
really work
three people a hundred thousand because
we can get three kids at 35 i think you
know
gary will help i think he has a good
sense like i think you could figure it
out
and if he's like [ __ ] you like then
you're like okay then then you go back
and you look at your wife and you look
at your [ __ ]
bank account you're like do i want to
put this up and if it has to be one at
35 to start you sure i'm going but that
that is the blueprint okay that is what
you need to do it will work
so everybody twenty four so we're not
twenty percent you know what people talk
about everything in the audience
yes everybody in the kitchen you do the
work
the second you realize that you're bar
stool and cnn and espn and vogue
the real the second you realize you're
that is the second you decide
okay if i'm that well who's who's the
writer
where's our like once you decide you're
actually a media company comma a human
being
you'll be off to the races got it
everybody everybody's like oh machine
learning
and all this is going to eliminate jobs
no it's not i have 22 full-time
employees for me as a human
do you know what the economy around a
human being's about to look like
like so here's beyonce and here's an
emerging
artist that's starting to make some
money let's say like you know right
t grizzly t grizzly in five years
is gonna have six full-time employees
not none
people that are just influencers on the
rise are gonna have more employees on
their payroll
than the biggest stars in the world if
he listens to me a year from now he's
gonna be writing out checks to more
employees for more money
than [ __ ] brad pitt for his business
maybe not for for nannies and [ __ ] yeah
but like for his business
because brad pitt's business is manager
and pr person
and agent agent and manager are working
on commission
pr person's their only overhead yeah
yeah
you know i get it me i'm [ __ ]
seven figures deep so are we right now
no no i'm talking my [ __ ] team
well my company yeah no not my company
i'm [ __ ] eight figures
nine figures deep actually you know
seven for me
that's what's going to happen okay cool
got it yes so appreciate it so it's the
balance of
you know just like you you know you have
the luxury of growing up in a family
business or if your uncle is the manager
and watching that and now doing it for
yourself on a business side
it's just getting the right cadence but
my big recommendation is it's a land
grab and anything you leave on the table
from one extra nice watch or trip
that you can put into another copywriter
you're gonna [ __ ] win 10 times over
when you're 41
and take it from somebody who's 42 it
feels just like 31.
and 33 and 37 is the same [ __ ] awesome
you know what i mean i appreciate your
time
thank you
[Music]
you